The names of all the continents end with the
same letter they begin with.
Mars has blue sunsets.
The fine dust in the atmosphere is just the
right size for blue light to penetrate more
efficiently than other colours in the spectrum.
The Golden Temple in the western Indian city
of Amristar runs a free kitchen operated by
volunteers that serves over 100,00 hot meals
a day.
It has been going for over 300 years.
When the world's largest diamond, the Cullinan
Diamond was transported from Africa to England,
an elaborate and secure journey by sea was
heavily publicised, but it was just a gigantic
distraction.
The diamond was simply posted by mail.
In 1946 a man claiming to be a detective gave
a pedestrian a camera and asked her to take
a picture of a suspect.
The "detective" turned out to be a gangster,
the "suspect" was actually his ex-wife, and
the "camera" was actually a concealed shotgun
that was fired by the camera shutter button.
In Japan, 'yaeba' or crooked teeth in girls
is considered cute and attractive.
Girls actually undergo procedures to un0straighten
their teeth.
Women end up digesting most of the lipstick
they apply.
In fact the average woman consumes about 3
kilograms of lipstick in her lifetime.
The average office desk has 400 times more
bacteria than a toilet.
The first time someone attempted to publish
the secrets of the Freemasons in 1826 he was
kidnapped and murdered.
A study at Oxford University found that for
every person you fall in love with, you lose
two close friends.
Hamsters only blink with one eye at a time.
In 2002, Steven Spielberg finally finished
college after a 33 years hiatus.
He turned in Schindler's List for his student
film requirement.
An olive tree can live up to 1,500 years.
A lump of pure gold the size of a matchbox
can be flattened into a sheet the size of
a tennis court.
Dormitory is an anagram for "Dirty Room".
Almonds are members of the peach family.
Accompanied by the cherry and plum.